[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
16 jahre im amt heute war für angela
merkel formell schluss in schloss
bellevue wurden sie und ihr kabinett von
bundespräsident steinmeier aus dem amt
verabschiedet ein förmlicher akte den
steinmeier aber feierlich nutzte für
dank und anerkennung
frau bundeskanzlerin wir haben ihnen
für 16 jahre zu danken in denen sie
unser land durch eine zeit geführt haben
die nicht eben armen an krisen und
verwerfungen wird
entlassungsurkunde und dann schnell weg
zu schnell für die fotografen
ich glaube sie müssen augenblick noch
für die kameras noch bleibt sie
geschäftsführend im amt und wollte
offenbar schnell wieder an die arbeit
typisch merkel die amtszeit der
bundeskanzlerin endet gemäß grundgesetz
mit der konstituierung des neuen
bundestages es ist der 20 wenn die
abgeordneten erstmals zusammenkommen
liegt alle vier jahre ein gewisser
zauber in der luft immer eine große
stunde der demokratie so war es trotz
coroner regeln auch heute wo zudem noch
die spitze das präsidium neu gewählt
wurde mit der neuen bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas werden wir später
in der sendung sprechen beginnen aber
zunächst mit andreas künast und einem
besonderen tag in berlin
es ist ja doch ein bisschen beruhigend
dass es anderen auch mal so geht misst
maske vergessen das staatsoberhaupt der
bundesrepublik deutschland müsste noch
eine im auto haben aber das ist jetzt
weg die bundestagsverwaltung hat für die
konstituierende sitzung besonders
strenge regeln erlassen und für schüssel
ein paar masken auf lager
weil der zwanzigste bundestag der größte
ist aller zeiten beengt und gedrängt hat
der bisherige parlamentspräsident
nehmen sie platz nur abgeordnete in den
saal gelassen die chinesen geimpft oder
getestet sind erkennbar am
schwarz-rot-goldenen handgelenks band
wir keinen nachweis bringen kann oder
will muss auf die tribüne
alle 23 sind von der afd dass
deutschland inzwischen nach china das
zweitgrößte parlament der welt hat ist
allen fraktionen irgendwie peinlich eine
wahlrechtsreform die diesen namen
verdient ist allerdings kein deut
leichter geworden und trotzdem sie
duldet ersichtlich keinen aufschub es
gibt am tag eins dieser wahlperiode neue
plätze zu sehen und neue platzprobleme
ganz hinten wo zum ersten mal seit 70
jahren der südschleswigsche
wählerverband einen sitz hat und ganz
vorn wo wie jedes mal neben der afd
niemand sitzen will nur dass diesmal die
fdp auf die ampel mehrheit zusteuert und
cdu/csu zum tauschen zwingen kann
gleich nach der wahl eine traditionelle
sitzordnung im plenum mit der
brechstange ändern zu wollen finde ich
es nicht gut das spiel und ich
spüre ein haufen
er tut den bisher mächtigen schon weh
der machtwechsel heute vollzogen wird
die spd bundestagsfraktion schlägt die
kollegin bärbel bas vor auf bärbel bas
die dritte bundestagspräsidentin die
erste zeit rita süßmuth werden
79,6 prozent entfallen damit bekommt sie
offensichtlich stimmen von allen seiten
und blumen auch
ich habe nicht selbst den finger gehoben
das stimmt aber ich habe im richtigen
moment ja gesagt neu unter den fünf vize
präsidentin yvonne mack was cdu aus
sachsen und aydan özoguz spd aus hamburg
das neue bundestagspräsidium gruppenbild
mit man die fdp scheitert auch am beginn
dieser legislaturperiode mit ihrem
vorschlag der thüringer michael kaufmann
wird wie erwartet nicht gewählt die
wenig nur eine fraktion die alternative
für deutschland im deutschen bundestag
ausgegrenzt wir werden millionen von
wählern
ausgegrenzt die uns gewählt haben topos
streit oder aus versöhnung 30 tage nach
der bundestagswahl beginnt etwas neues
für die bundesregierung für den
bundestag für das deutsche vaterland
[Musik]
jünger etwas weiblicher bunter ist der
neue bundestag fast 40 prozent der
abgeordneten erstmals dabei und sie
gerade sie bekamen heute eine lehrstunde
in demokratie vom bisherigen
bundestagspräsidenten länger als er fast
50 jahre ist keiner im parlament und so
eröffnete wolfgang schäuble als
alterspräsident die sitzung seine
vielleicht letzte große rede war auch
ein stück vermächtnis nun zieht sich der
79-jährige auf die hinter bänke zurück
dürfte aber auch dort eine größe bleiben
matthias feld hat schaut zurück
es ist ein kurzer moment der rührung das
gesamte haus spendet dem scheidenden
bundestag verwirrenden einen letzten
applaus und wolfgang schäuble reagiert
so wie wolfgang schäuble so reagiert
sprechen sie mich bitte nicht zu sehr in
rührung
wolfgang schäuble ist irgendwie schon
immer da er war minister unter helmut
kohl und unter angela merkel
er war fraktionschef und zuletzt
bundestagspräsident immer dabei immer
mittendrin nach gott das war mein erstes
wahlplakat das sieht man dass man doch
auch älter wird und
das war einer der größten augenblick in
meiner politischen laufbahn als ich den
vertrag zur deutschen einheit mit lothar
de maizière und günther krause
unterzeichnet habe
erinnerungen an damals und heute
schäuble kann nicht loslassen er will
gebraucht werden ich denke dass in
diesen zeiten ganz großer veränderungen
das wichtige ist noch ein wenig
erfahrung von älteren einzubringen
mit dem platzwechsel wird wolfgang
schäuble jetzt noch mehr zum gewissen
der republik einer der mahnt aber auch
ermahnt
wie nach dem attentat von hanau als er
sprache und umgang in der gesellschaft
für die grauenhafte tat
mitverantwortlich macht solche
wahnsinnstaten geschehe nicht im
luftleeren raum sie wachsen in einem
vergifteten gesellschaftlichen klima in
denen das ressentiment gegenüber dem
fremden und abwegig die
verschwörungstheorien geschürt werden
oder als das verkorkste ende des
afghanistan-einsatzes einen
scherbenhaufen hinterlässt und
verantwortung hin und her geschoben wird
die verzweiflung der menschen am
flughafen in kabul
zerreißt einem das herz
und ihr schicksal
erschüttert das selbstverständnis des
westens unser selbstverständnis
in wenigen tagen ist zusammengebrochen
was wir im bündnis über zwei jahrzehnte
mit aufgebaut haben auch heute in seiner
letzten rede vom platz des präsidenten
mahnt er diesmal die abgeordneten am
verhalten jedes einzelnen von uns auch
das mussten wir zuletzt wieder erfahren
hängt die würde dieses hauses wir haben
es in der hand ob die bürgerinnen und
bürgern dieser volksvertretung das
schenken worauf die parlamentarische
demokratie aufbaut nämlich ihr vertrauen
nicht angehen wolfgang schäuble übergibt
das zepter an seine nachfolgerin und
kehrt zurück in die reihen der
abgeordneten dorthin wo er mal von 49
jahren begonnen hat
und an die nachfolgerin die dritte frau
erst die dritte frau an der spitze des
bundestags nach annemarie renger und
nach rita süssmuth die die wahl heute
miterlebte und so kommentierte
bisher gezeigt dass wir es auch genauso
gut wie die männer gab an
dass bärbel bas geboren 1968 in duisburg
seit 1900 1988 ist die ökonomen für
personalmanagement mitglied der spd seit
2009 im bundestag
übrigens immer direkt gewählt seit 2009
10 war sie stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende mit den
schwerpunkten gesundheit bildung und
forschung
und nun ist sie uns zugeschaltet schönen
guten abend frau präsidentin hallo frau
waas schönen guten abend seit 1949 sind
sie die dritte frau in diesem hohen amt
sie haben ihre wahl heute selbst als
zeitenwende bezeichnet eine wende wohin
eine wende wie ich das auch im parlament
gespürt habe einfach auch an den vielen
gesichtern in den unterschiedlichen
fraktionen hin in richtung auch
modernisierung des staates aber auch der
verwaltung und auch des parlaments das
ist für mich deshalb etwas wichtiges und
natürlich die dritte frau zu sein auch
das ist glaube ich nach so langer zeit
auch eine kleine zeitenwende nun ist der
bundestag wieder etwas weiblicher
geworden aber mit einem anteil von unter
35 prozent immer noch von parität ja
weit entfernt woran liegt das ihrer
meinung nach was ist ihre erklärung
wollen die frauen nicht oder werden sie
von männern ausgebremst
also viele frauen wollen schon aber es
ist auch immer wieder ein thema politik
und familie auch zu vereinbaren und es
ist ja immer noch so dass viele frauen
eben nach wie vor auch die familie um
sich herum haben möchten und deshalb
zögern vielleicht auch die ein oder
anderen auf der anderen seite ist es
auch so es liegt an unserem wahlrecht
das wird ja noch eine reform in dieser
legislatur so bin ich doch vor hoffnung
dass das passiert dass wir vielleicht
auch zu dem bereich der parität noch was
tun können im wahlrecht aber es liegt
auch daran dass natürlich viele in den
wahlkreisen direkt 110 jetzt habe ich in
duisburg das glück das man
mich auch direkt aufgestellt hatten ich
konnte in den bundestag einziehen und da
müssen sich natürlich viele frauen auch
in den wahlkreisen durchsetzen und ich
hoffe dass ich ein gutes beispiel dafür
geben kann in zukunft haben sie sich
eigentlich geärgert dass ihre partei die
spd nicht gleich auf sie gekommen ist
auch da brauchte es ja zunächst mal
internen und externen druck zumal von
frauen damit die männer nicht unter sich
ausmachen es sind immer sozusagen noch
die gleichen probleme haben sie sich
geärgert
ich habe mich letztendlich nicht
geärgert weil ich weiß ich kenne jetzt
rolf mützenich auch schon lange und er
hat die position die er besetzen konnte
das waren in seiner zeit als
fraktionsvorsitzende sechs positionen
die hat ja alle mit frauen besetzt also
ihm kann man jetzt wirklich nicht
vorwerfen dass er das nicht im blick
gehabt hätte jetzt erben sie von
wolfgang schäuble eine grad schon
angesprochen und erledigte
wahlrechtsreform die ihnen gelingen muss
sie wollen das anpacken haben sich das
auf die fahnen geschrieben was macht sie
denn zuversichtlich voraus dass sie
irgendetwas an der stelle erreichen da
haben sich ja alle bisher die zähne
daran ausgebissen
zum einen haben wir im wahlrecht auch
beschrieben dass wir im wahlgesetz
beschrieben dass wir eine
reformkommission ja einsetzen das ist
das eine ich bin aber auch sehr
zuversichtlich weil ich auch gehört habe
dass die parteien die jetzt in die
koalitionsverhandlungen gehen dieses
thema auch in während der
koalitionsverhandlungen wollen das werde
ich auch sicherlich noch abwarten
ansonsten das habe ich heute in meiner
ansprache auch schon gesagt werde ich
die fraktion auffordern dieses thema zu
beginn der legislatur auf die
tagesordnung zu setzen auch die
kommission dann einzurichten so dass wir
hoffentlich dann auch wirklich zu
ergebnissen kommen ich finde es höchste
zeit
die afg ist im deutschen bundestag nicht
mehr die größte oppositionspartei wird
aber kaum ihre ständigen provokationen
aufgeben das war auch heute ja schon zu
beobachten und sie haben ein bisschen
strenge
durchklingen lassen fand ich war mein
eindruck mit welcher strategie werden
sie der afg begegnen
also ich werde natürlich mir das
anschauen es ist immer situativ
natürlich auch die fdp-fraktion hat alle
möglichkeiten die die geschäftsordnung
hergibt aber ich werde darauf achten das
habe ich heute auch gesagt mir ist schon
wichtig dass wir die würde des hauses
auch bei den debatten die strittig sind
und auch anstrengend werden auch in
zukunft noch dass die würde des hauses
gewalt und ich auch nicht zulassen werde
dass beschimpfung oder dass wir uns
tatsächlich als abgeordnete gegenseitig
schlecht machen das hat für mich einen
hohen anspruch und da werde ich auch
einschreiten ob das dann streng wirkt
das muss vielleicht auch manchmal so
sein aber ist mir geht mir eigentlich um
die würde des hauses und das finde ich
muss auch von einer fdp fraktion gewahrt
sein und deshalb werde ich da schon ein
auge darauf haben dass das aber auch
alle fraktionen einhalten ergänzende
frage frau war seit 2017 ist kfd
vertreter zum vize-präsidenten gewählt
worden auch heute gab es keine mehrheit
für den kandidaten der afd sollte das so
bleiben oder sollte es in afg vize
präsidenten geben
grundsätzlich steht ja jeder fraktion
ein vizepräsident oder eine vize
präsident hinzu aber letztendlich habe
ich das nicht zu werten es ist eine
geheime wahl und alle abgeordneten
entscheiden in ihrer wahlkabine bei der
geheimen wahl ob sie eine person wählen
möchten in dieses amt oder nicht frau
waas frau bundestagspräsidentin
herzlichen dank für den besuch im
heute-journal gerne vielen dank
das gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet wenn sie noch mehr über
den bundestag erfahren wollen etwa zum
frauenanteil welches alter welche berufe
die abgeordneten haben online haben wir
das und mehr aufgelistet in unserer zdf
heute
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
anderen wichtigen nachrichten des tages
unterlag auf die zahl der korona
infektionen steigt in vielen
europäischen ländern und auch in
deutschland weiter an deswegen drängen
gesundheitsexperten auf rasche
auffrischungsimpfungen vor allem für
über 70-jährige und menschen mit einem
geschwächten immunsystem sowie für das
pflegepersonal auch zunächst mit johnson
& johnson geimpfte sollten eine booster
impfung erhalten das robert koch
institut meldet zehn 1473 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages
3702 mehr als vor einer woche 128
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
inzidenz ist auf 113 gestiegen
im prozess um einen rassistischen
angriff in einer erfurter straßenbahn
ist der täter zu vier jahren und neun
monaten haft verurteilt worden wegen
gefährlicher körperverletzung nötigung
und sachbeschädigung ende april hatte
der 41-jährige deutsche einen jungen
syrer rassistisch beleidigt und brutal
angegriffen der mann hatte die tat
gestanden und auf alkohol und kokain
konsum zurück geführt sein verteidiger
kündigte revision an
nach dem militärputsch im sudan hat
deutschland die entwicklungshilfe für
das nordostafrikanische land vorerst
eingestellt ebenso wie die usa in new
york berät der un sicherheitsrat zur
stunde in einer dringlichkeitssitzung
über die lage dort mehrere mitglieder
der entmachteten regierung darunter
ministerpräsident hamburg stehen in
khartum unter hausarrest
general albuch hahn kündigte an das
militär werde sich zurückziehen sobald
eine neue zivile regierung ernannt sei
die zahl der todesopfer bei protesten
gegen den putsch ist auf sieben
gestiegen
vor der griechischen insel kos ist ein
schlauchboot mit 27 flüchtlingen
untergegangen eine frau und drei kinder
ertranken
22 menschen konnten von der griechischen
küstenwache gerettet werden die
migranten waren vor von der türkischen
küste aus aufgebrochen wie bislang mehr
als 2500 menschen in diesem jahr
griechenland erhob schwere vorwürfe
gegen die türkei schleuser müssten daran
gehindert werden das leben von
flüchtlingen auf dem meer aufs spiel zu
setzen
wenige tage vor beginn des
weltklimagipfels in glasgow wird die
größe der aufgabe immer deutlicher den
menschengemachten klimawandel
einzudämmen heute kam von der un
warnungen die nationalen aktionspläne
reichten bei weitem nicht aus um die
erderwärmung auf 1,5 grad zu begrenzen
der neue plan hierzulande muss in
koalitionsverhandlungen erst noch
ausgearbeitet werden aber die aufgaben
sind gewaltig der energiebedarf für den
umbau der industrie ist immens ebenso
für die weitere digitalisierung die man
sich auf die fahnen geschrieben hat
alles hängt mit allem zusammen das zeigt
auch das beispiel von elisabeth schmitt
es ist ein typischer abend in dieser
studentenwohnung in hannover fast 20
jahre produziert musik für seinen
youtube kanal und schaut dann mit seiner
freundin vanessa eine sendung per
videostream die beiden sind einen
großteil ihres tages online
kombination aus netflix aus arbeit an
den audio sachen aus youtube kanal
pflegen aus surfen instagram alles
mögliche sechs bis acht stunden am tag
mit sicherheit dafür nötig energie je
nach szenario verbraucht die it und
kommunikationstechnik weltweit
inzwischen 15 bis 20 prozent des
gesamten strombedarfs und produziert
damit bereits halb so viel co2 wie der
flugverkehr bei jeder whatsapp nachricht
bei jeder e-mail werden daten in
rechenzentren verarbeitet allein in den
vergangenen zehn jahren ist der
energiebedarf der rechenzentren in
deutschland um 60 prozent gestiegen
tendenz weiter steigend besonders seit
der korona pandemie viele zentren
arbeiten aber weder effizient noch
nachhaltig alles was an strom in einem
rechenzentrum reingeht geht als wärme
wieder raus aus dem rechenzentrum und
diese wärme kann ich nutzen um zum
beispiel gebäude zu heizen in frankfurt
dem großen rechenzentrums hotspot in
deutschland und würde die abwärme aus
dem rechenzentrum ausreichen um die
ganze stadt frankfurt mit wärme zu
versorgen
fakt ist es gibt keine gesetzliche
pflicht für rechenzentren ihre
energiebilanz offenzulegen und das ist
unklar wie viel energie und emissionen
überhaupt eingespart werden könnten das
umweltbundesamt hat das am beispiel
video streaming untersucht ergebnis das
größte einsparpotenzial gibt es neben
den rechenzentren im heimnetzwerk immer
wenn es möglich ist über wlan er seine
netz verbindung herzustellen
zwischen wlan und mobilfunk liegt
ungefähr ein faktor 25 also 25 mal mehr
co2 emittieren ich wenn ich über mein
mobilfunk ins internet gehe
digitalisierung kann aber auch zum
klimaschutz beitragen eine stunde video
konferenz produziert laut studie gerade
einmal so viel co2 wie 260 meter
autofahren klima schonen heißt auch
geräte wie smartphones möglichst lange
nutzen und selbst rechenzentren können
nachhaltig beispiel tüv nord hier werden
server hauptsächlich per freiluft und
nicht per klimaanlage kühlt spart strom
spart geld
gespannt mit den mit der heutigen
technologie verglichen zu einem
konventionellen rechenzentrum über
450.000 euro pro jahr ein wir konnten
das gesamte jahr sehr energieeffizientes
rechenzentrum kühlen und haben damit in
diesem jahr zwischen 400 und 500 tonnen
co2 eingespart
auch für student love ist klimaschutz
wichtig beim surfen oder streamen wille
aber keine abstriche machen er hofft
dass auch die digitale welt nachhaltiger
wird
ja wir können das klappen mehr energie
nachhaltig gewonnen die frage aus der wg
in hannover wird derzeit auch beim
gipfel der eu energieminister in
luxemburg erörtert und dabei feiert nun
tatsächlich eine energieart wieder
fröhliche urständ die jedenfalls bei uns
erledigt scheint die atomkraft in
deutschland dürfte das so bleiben aber
auf eu ebene wird diskutiert ob
atomenergie den grünen stempel bekommt
und damit auch investitionsgelder
florian 9 berichtet
elektrische straßenbahnen tradition in
luxemburg die frage woher bezahlbarer
strom nicht nur dafür in zukunft kommt
wird hier auch an diesem morgen gestellt
sondersitzung der eu energieminister es
dauert nur ein paar minuten da fällt vor
dem ratsgebäude das reizwort schlechthin
kernkraft und forschende leider werden
erneuerbare energien allein nicht
ausreichen wir brauchen insbesondere
atomenergie nuklear
thom energie die untote der
energiedebatte verteufelt wegen des
immer noch ungelösten müllproblems
gefürchtet wegen der risiken nach dem
unglück von fukushima in deutschland zum
abriss freigegeben anderswo dagegen
gefeiert als klima schonende form der
energiegewinnung so weit so bekannt was
sich dieser tage ändert das atom fans
wie frankreichs präsident makro
plötzlich auf einem eu-gipfel oberwasser
haben zur eigenen verwunderung
ich habe noch nie habe ich in den
letzten vier jahren auf einem eu gipfel
eine so große und so klare unterstützung
erlebt für unseren kurs dass die
atomenergie brauchen um unsere
klimaziele zu erreichen
tatsächlich stehen die mit abstand
meisten atommeiler der eu in frankreich
und deutschland seine verbliebenen sechs
ende des nächsten jahres stilllegen wird
werden anderswo neu gebaut in frankreich
finnland und der slowakei oder konkret
geplant wie etwa in ungarn rumänien
tschechien die große streitfrage in
brüssel verbirgt sich nun wie so oft
hinter einem furchtbar technokratischen
titel taxonomie das heißt erstmals will
die kommission verbindlich festlegen
welche investitionen als grün gelten
etwa auch die in atomkraft
passen in den letzten monaten hat das
massiven politischen druck geschrieben
die atomkraft in die gäste der
nachhaltigen investitionen aufzunehmen
frankreich war definitiv der anführer
dieser chor
und scheint sich durchzusetzen
schon spricht kommissionspräsidentin
ursula von der leyen von atomkraft als
stabiler energiequelle und selbst
deutschland leistet offenbar nur
halbherzig wieder vermutlich nicht ohne
gegenleistung
das könnte in diese richtung gehen dass
wir den kompromiss haben dass frankreich
kernenergie nutzt und co2 schnell zu
reduzieren deutschland gas als
brückentechnologie nutzen will realos
würde die glaubwürdigkeit dieser
taxonomie extrem beschädigt wenn sie gas
und atom energie als grün deklarieren
das wäre das ende einer grünen
definition von nachhaltigkeit
es wäre ein klasse sprißler kompromiss
für jeden etwas nur das eigentliche ziel
geräte leicht aus dem blick und
jetzt nochmal nachrichten runde lag auf
die erhöhung von konto gebühren und
entgelten ohne aktive zustimmung der
bankkunden hatte im frühjahr den
bundesgerichtshof beschäftigt heute nun
hat die finanzaufsicht bafin die banken
aufgefordert das urteil zu ungültigen
erhöhungen umzusetzen frank bethmann was
bedeutet das für die geldhäuser auf der
einen und die bankkunden auf der anderen
seite für die banken ist das ganz klar
ein mahngang die finanzaufsicht fordert
unmissverständlich von der kreditbranche
dass sie das folgenschwere urteil der
karlsruher richter umsätze denn bislang
ist wenig passiert die kundenforderungen
nach rückerstattung blieben
weitestgehend ungehört nun also
verschärft sich der ton das urteil des
bgh hat auswirkungen auf fast jede bank
kundenbeziehung erklärte der bafin
präsident mark branson heute umso
wichtiger ist eine schnelle
unbürokratische
transparente umsetzung branson der neue
bafin-chef zeigt erstmals kannte das
gebühren urteil das in der branche hohe
wellen geschlagen hat scheint dafür gut
geeignet die banken so die bafin müsste
in ihren kunden klar und verständlich
über die folgen des urteils informieren
die kunden nachträglich um zustimmung zu
den aktuellen gebühren bitten und
gegebenenfalls entgelte die ohne
explizite einwilligung erhoben wurden
zurückzahlen der deutsche sparkassen und
giroverband reagierte umgehend und
erklärte dass die kreditwirtschaft den
richterspruch bereits umsätze was die
aktive einholung von der zustimmung von
kunden anbelangt für die einzelnen
sparkassen gesprochen würden die
rückerstattung ansprüche geprüft und die
bafin stellte klar dass mit ihr nicht zu
spaßen sei auch eine härtere gangart sei
denkbar vielen dank nach frankfurt
er kommt zum fußball da gibt es einiges
die deutsche nationalmannschaft der
frauen hat auch ihr viertes spiel der wm
qualifikation gewonnen mit dem klaren 7
0 sieg gegen israel festigt das deutsche
team die tabellenführung in der gruppe h
und auf nationaler ebene steht heute für
fußballer die zweite runde des
dfb-pokals an die sieger der bereits
beendeten spiele stehen im achtelfinale
preußen münster verlor gegen hertha bsc
1 zu 3 der sv babelsberg 03 gegen rb
leipzig im 0 zu 1 die tsg hoffenheim
besiegte holstein kiel 5 zu 1 1860
münchen gewann gegen schalke 04 1 zu 0
und borussia dortmund besiegte den fc
ingolstadt
20 dazu später im update 1 spielbericht
neuer trainer des vfl wolfsburg ist nun
florian coesfeld der 39 jährige frühere
coach von werder bremen folgt auf mark
van bommel interims trainer michael
frontzeck rückt nach nur einem tag
wieder in die zweite reihe
auf der kanaren insel la palma ist er
seit fünf wochen brodelnde vulkan noch
einmal aktiver geworden er sei in einer
neuen phase die weitaus intensiver sei
erklären wissenschaftlern ein
vulkankrater ist teilweise
zusammengebrochen ist bilden sich neue
lavaströme die bislang nicht betroffene
gebiete erreichen mehr als 2000 gebäude
sind bereits zerstört die lava bedeckt
mehr als 900 hektar land hunderte
unterschiedlich starke erdbeben
erschüttern dazu die insel die menschen
dort sehen ein ende des vulkanausbruchs
herbei
so viel vom heute schon mal für den
moment bei 37 grad geht es heute um
palliativmedizin ja ein schweres thema
aber nicht nur es ist auch ein film
darüber wie viel gutes schönes und
tröstliches am lebensende noch möglich
ist titel die letzten guten tage jetzt
hier im anschluss und sehr
empfehlenswert
und um mitternacht ist hier wieder zeit
für unser heute-journal update mit wulf
schmiese so ist es bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend beginnen wir den
wetterbericht mal an der ostküste
nordamerikas denn hier rund um new york
fallen enorme regenmengen 100 liter pro
quadratmeter
klingt ja schon mal ganz schön viel aber
was in sizilien schon runter gekommen
ist ist deutlich mehr das waren 300
liter pro quadratmeter
und dieses tief über dem zentralen
mittelmeer das wird uns auch in den
nächsten tagen beschäftigen mit
kräftigen gewittern und weiteren
regenfällen über dem warmen mittelmeer
wasser kann es sich immer wieder
regeneriert bei uns hatten wir es heute
mit einer kaltfront zu tun von dem tief
jascha morgen kommt dass die calli
heranbringt aber vor allen dingen nur
norddeutschland dichtere wolken und dann
kommt das hoch rosamunde davor
allerdings wird es noch mal richtig mild
mit eifel fühlen könnte es sogar mal für
19 vielleicht sogar 20 grad in der
kölner bucht reicht heute nacht fällt
regen hier in norddeutschland bei einem
starkem bis stürmischem südwestwind im
süden ist es dagegen klar da bildet sich
mal nebel oder dunst die temperaturen
zeigen ein deutliches nord west süd ost
gefälle im nordwesten sinken sie auf 12
bis 10 im südosten auf 3 bis 0 grad dort
droht wurden frost morgen liegen die
temperaturen in bayern bei 11 bis 14
grad sonst etwas milder besonders wie
gesagt in der kölner bucht mit bis zu 19
grad oder 20 nach nehmen und uns zeigt
sich in süddeutschland magen häufig die
sonne am vormittag ist es in
norddeutschland noch stärker bewirken es
gibt noch etwas regen an der küste in
den nächsten tagen geht es dann mit
ruhigen herbstwetter weiter im nebel bei
9 im sonnenschein bei 19 grad guten
abend